introduction of the vapor fly to the
running community really has changed um
what we think of as possible for running
particularly in the marathon these shoes
certainly are
game changing and transformative this is
a very sizable seismic shift these are
nike's vapor flies
critics say the sneakers provide an
unfair advantage to those who race in
them and that their revolutionary design
threatens the very integrity of the
sport itself so does the technology
inside them give an unfair advantage and
should they be banned from competition
with the tokyo olympics around the
corner this summer these are the
questions facing the world of
competitive
[Music]
on running 12 2019 elite marathoner
elliot khachogi
ran 26.2 miles in less than two hours
breaking one of sport's greatest
barriers bridgette
the next day fellow kenyan bridget
coskey shattered the woman's marathon
record in chicago
what both runners had in common was what
was on their feet both athletes were
wearing versions of nike's vaporfly
racing shoes which according to the
company allow runners to improve their
times by up to 4.2 percent
and if recent records are any indication
those claims may actually be true since
the vapor flies were released male
runners in the nike shoes have run five
of the top 10 fastest marathon times
ever recorded and it's not just the
elites that have embraced the vapor fly
if you visit the starting lines of any
road race in the united states today
from a major marathon to a local 5k
chances are you'll come across the
distinctive neon sneakers
but nike's success hasn't come without
controversy ever since the shoes were
introduced in 2017 they've ignited a
fierce debate about whether the vapor
flies should be banned from competition
until now track's international
governing body world athletics has
provided only a loose guideline on
sneaker tech shoes must not be
constructed so as to give athletes any
unfair assistance or advantage
in a statement to the wall street
journal nike said we respect world
athletics in the spirit of their rules
and we do not create any running shoes
that return more energy than the runner
expense
but with the tokyo olympics around the
corner this july world athletics
launched an investigation into the vapor
flies the results of which are expected
before the end of the month
a person in the street could say well
why would you not use them because they
give you an advantage
the same people might say well why don't
you allow doping because
that can be accessible to everybody and
if it doesn't harm them then why can't
they
just do doping and some people have
suggested that the shoe issue right now
is a form of mechanical doping peter
thompson has spent his career coaching
professional distance runners all over
the world you've got alberto salazar
rudy chapa like many in the running
community he thinks the vapor flies
should be banned from competition to
protect the integrity of the sport the
definition of cheating is doing
something to deliberately gain an unfair
advantage why are we doing our sport are
we doing it purely for performance or is
it for the competition of person against
person
if it's about competition person against
person
then
the need for 11 level playing field is
is exemplified
to find out why the vapor flies have
proven to be such a breakthrough in shoe
design we visited the university of
michigan's orthopedic research
laboratory forward dissection
today we're going to cut open a pair of
nike vapor fly next percent to see
what's inside
so this shoe has different features that
i'd like to point out to you first the
shoe has a new type of foam pbacks which
nike calls zoom x is a foam found in
airplane insulation that is squishier
bouncier and lighter than the foams
typically found in running shoes second
you can see the full length carbon fiber
plate
and this carbon fiber plate
adds a lot of stiffness and stability to
the shoe as well
the science behind how the vaporfly's
foam plate system works still isn't
entirely clear but what is is that this
technology could be transformative for
the sport
we're in a place right now where there
is a before the vapor fly and after the
vapor fly period we're in we're in the
transition period right now it's a very
uncomfortable place as a fan of the
sport and as a competitor in the sport
jeff burns is a professional ultra
runner and a university of michigan
doctoral candidate in biomechanics
last year burns co-authored a paper in
which he argued for a compromise
between those who would like to see the
shoes banned from competition and those
who see the vapor flies as the next step
in the sport's technological innovation
so my co-author and i recommended
that we simply regulate the midsole
thickness of the shoe much like weighing
our shot puts before we throw them the
idea is limit the thickness of the
midsole so then now moving forward we
have a definition that shoes are
40 millimeters our shoes are 35
millimeters our shoes are 45 millimeters
or less we have that space in which to
innovate
until the vapor flies came along
marathon racing shoes mostly relied on
thin rubber soles the big idea being the
lighter the shoes the faster you run
for years shoe companies have offered
products to improve performance but at
least for running no one product clips
the competition in the same way the
vapor flies have today
so in distance running there hasn't been
a profound technological advancement in
the past 40 to 50 years
the vapor fly represents the first time
that we've seen a distinct seismic shift
in
something that benefits performance
burns proposal allows for shoes like the
vapor flies to remain in competition but
with clear limits on how the technology
can be developed going forward
this middle ground approach in sport
isn't without precedent i am wearing the
fastest suit in the world and that's a
fact during the 2008 olympics in beijing
every swimmer who could get one was
wearing speedo's laser bodysuit
developed with help from nasa the laser
was a technological breakthrough in
swimwear design that cut down on the
body's friction and water by mimicking
shark skin and world records
just crashed fina the world governing
body of swimming banned the suit after
an unprecedented number of swimmers
broke world records in it but finis
policy like burns proposal was a
compromise
although full-length suits were banned
the laser's revolutionary material is
still permitted in competition swimwear
we wanted to get a runner's first-hand
account of how the vapor flies compared
to the competition so burns recruited a
fellow competitive marathoner and
olympic marathon trials qualifier yuris
cylinex
so to compare the vapor fly with
conventional shoe the adidas adios boost
we're going to have you run two miles on
the treadmill the plan was to have yuris
run a mile in his training shoes adidas
adios boost and it's the shoe that the
previous marathon world record was set
in
and then a mile in the vapor flies
[Music]
good work dude
how did it feel in the shoes they're
great yeah i mean i haven't had a shoe
that's like it
it's the energy return you feel like
you're
you can hear the bouncing
on the ground but when you're running on
the knees
interacting in the ground in these
everything you just feel it way more
yeah harder like you feel
like you feel the pounding a little bit
more and in the vapor flies you're just
on a nice pillow
with the olympic trials approaching this
june qualifiers like cylinex are waiting
for world athletics's guidance on what
they'll be allowed to lace up in come
race day